okay here we go hello everyone and
welcome back to
book club you know this one is a
spontaneous one
um i think this might be our 12th book
club
something like that 12th or 13th book
club we were supposed to be done two
weeks ago
but i was enjoying myself too much and
so we decided to throw this one in
spontaneously
um because it's fun we're back on
linkedin facebook
youtube and twitter welcome everyone
from around the world
uh who's here today let's do uh dakota
potato peel and pie literary society you
guys i think you've been here
a dozen times hello from new zealand uh
from prague that's where my family's
from cynic is a czech name
um new finland newfees in the house
alberta scottsdale arizona uh malaysia
how are you
uh socal always good to see you swindon
nice to see you again romania this is
insane how many people are here
uh this is wonderful i just love how
global we are hello iceland
i love iceland i saw what do you call it
northern lights i saw the
aurora borealis when i was there is
magical magical magical
um toronto and
italy where in italy i love italy um
okay let's talk about together's better
um i'll tell you the history of where
this book came from
uh as always i'm gonna tell you a little
bit about the book
and uh we'll take some live questions
and we have some uh questions that you
sent into book club so thanks very much
for those okay so this book
wasn't supposed to be um i was sitting
in my publisher's office
and i was just we were just we our
meeting was done and we were just
you know in it um and
they were talking about twitter two two
of the people at the publishing company
were talking about twitter
and they looked down at me and they said
you have a twitter account right and i
went
yep they said do you use it i'm like i
don't use it like everybody else i said
i just post quotes i just post
little thoughts that i have but that's
all i do
um and he looked at me and he said well
how many followers do you have
and i don't remember what the number was
but it was a it was a couple hundred
thousand
and he said really i said yeah
he's like i didn't know that that that
you had that
i'm like well you know i like sharing
and so
i said why don't we do something with
all the quotes people seem to like them
i'd like to make a quote book
he said fine and that's literally how
this came to be
so my contract actually said untitled
tweet book
nobody knew it was going to be including
me i just said i i have an idea
there's going to be untitled tweet book
and then
then the craziness began um i decided i
wanted to be illustrated so we found a
wonderful illustrator ethan aldridge
who's fantastic
um and i wanted it to i was inspired by
children's books
i didn't want to just do a plain you
know quote book although that was boring
so i went to literally went to the
bookshop and was looking at children's
books and there was a little book called
there was a book called um
oh what was it called it's called how to
have an idea or something
there's this magical little children's
book about an egg that represents an
idea i just loved it
and that became the inspiration for this
book and because i wanted to
be modeled after a children's book even
though it's technically for adults
i wanted it to be long so this these are
my bookmarks this
piece is a tissue these this is a
standard size small book but i wanted to
go this way
which they told me i can't do i said yes
come on we can do it so we got
so the first the first struggle we had
to have was making the book go sideways
um and everybody thought i was crazy at
the company my publisher believed in me
but everybody thought i'd gone on my
rocker and we're calling him
and saying why are you publishing this
this book it's a freaking children's
book for adults that's not gonna sell
um and then i said i wanted it scented i
was at a
an event and i was sitting next to this
uh these two women uh
dawn and samantha goldworm from a
company called 1229
and i asked them what they did and they
they designed scents for brands
like they sent you know mercedes or
something launches a new car and that
the show
that has a special scent things like
that and i said well have you ever sent
it a book they said i don't think it's
ever been done i'm like
can it be done they said yeah there's
new technology we could do that i said
well i'd like to send a book
so i went back to the publisher and said
and i'm getting a custom design
scent from this amazing company on the
smell of optimism
and we should put it in the book well
that was also another struggle
anyway eventually the book got made and
here it is and there's a few wonderful
little things that you'll notice about
it
all of those handwritten pages i wanted
i wanted the book to be human
it's got all of these sensory things
it's got color it's got
visual it's got smell it's got a song at
the end
the we made the cover a little softer
i purposely never brought it out in
digital because i wanted to only exist
in reality
uh because it was the most human thing i
could it could do in a book
it has all these wonderful things all
the handwritten pages that you see
the little chapter sections that's
actually my handwriting i sat
there and wrote every single one of
those pages they just
they just printed them uh so that's
actually my handwriting
uh the song at the back by aloe blacc uh
i asked aloe uh if he would write in his
handwriting
the the lyrics so you'll see all of the
lyrics are handwritten
uh that's actually alo's handwriting uh
so
all of it was was designed to be organic
and human
and just a lot of fun and of course the
best part
um i dedicated it to my sister as you
see it says for sarah i'll follow you
anywhere
and i didn't want her to know and
because we work together she sees all of
the things that are happening so we had
to make special
you know we in in the publishing
industry they come out with something
called galleys which is a
a soft cover pre-published edition
basically so we can all see what it
looks like
we send it to press things like that we
had to make
all of the galleys all of the pdfs
everything we had to make it without the
dedication page
because i didn't want sarah to see it so
we had this whole conspiracy
that she could never see it until the
book came out and then when the book
came out
um we surprised her and showed it to her
and i should introduce you to sarah sir
come over here and say hello
this is sarah this is my sister sarah
who we work together
we're like best friends the book is
dedicated to her and i would follow her
anywhere and follow you anywhere you
make me cry i know
i'll go back
okay let's talk about uh together is
better shall we
by the way this is my favorite picture
in the whole thing
uh that kind of represents these three
kids sitting getting ready to go on
their adventure
um staring at the wall i think is a is a
feeling we've all had before like should
i shouldn't i do i do this do i not do
this
do i take the plunge do i go on the
journey do i do the difficult thing do i
leave
the the certainty of the known even if
it's uncomfortable to go on the
the uncertain adventure and um
and i think the quote perfectly captures
is a vision is like a dream it will
disappear unless we do something with it
do something bigger do something small
but stop
wondering and go on an adventure i love
everything about that that that the
original illustration is actually
hanging in my
hanging in my office from what i i mean
i haven't been to my office in
six months but it's there um okay
uh i can tell you a couple more stories
if you like but why don't we do some
uh
questions i'll tell you one more thing
so how did i come up with the story
the story is actually cut and dry based
on
uh joseph campbell if you know your
joseph campbell hero's journey
it's star wars it's uh uh
lord of the rings it's it's you know
this hero's journey is heroes arc
where we have our heroes who go on this
journey and first they meet uh
someone uh a mage or something who sends
them on their journey that's that's the
the woman at the beginning
and then they face all these trials and
tribulations and then they're they don't
like each other and then they come
together forced to come together and
they discover something wonderful and
the temptation is to stay there
but then they have to bring it back
because the ultimate
of the uh the ultimate trial of the hero
is not to just discover the thing of
magic
but to come and share it with other
people and these wonderful kids go on
this journey for a better playground
they find the better playground it's a
magical place it's utopia
and make the very difficult decision to
leave utopia to go back to their old
playground but what they do is they
bring that vision to life
for the people that they left and that
is really the journey that i hope that
we're all on that that we're all looking
to find some magic in our lives and
share it with others this is definitely
the journey that i've been on
when i discovered my why it created a
passion and made like no other
and i thought i have to share this um
it's not good enough for us to find
passion in our own jobs
it is right for us to find ways to share
that passion with other people so they
can feel it too
there we go okay should we do some
questions
um uh
also by the way i love this picture
because that to me represents what
leadership really is leadership is not
getting the crown leadership is not
getting the power leadership is the
ability to get it and give it away
and that's what what this kid does he
he's given the crown but then he
immediately
passes it off to someone else who he
trusts and loves
um i actually took that picture and put
it on stationery
um okay let's do some questions why
don't we
um and if i think of any more stories
i'll tell you them
uh but i do really love this little book
it it turned out to be such a surprise
and by the way like i said
my publisher gave me top cover because
his ceo called him up and said
what are you doing they thought it was a
big waste of money um they thought it
was
that it was just some vanity project
that simon was doing
and like it caused a lot of stink in the
company and
um here's the funny thing the book
actually debuted on the new york times
bestseller list
no no but nobody expected nobody was
even checking
i i called the publisher and said
somebody emailed me you weren't
you're not going to believe this no one
was looking so it turned out that
um i'm not the only person who likes
magical little sweet little books
okay uh janet packer from yorkshire
england how are you
is it the person or the vision that
people follow and why
what a good question so visions tend to
be
ethereal um they exist in our
imaginations
and as human beings we do a lot better
with
tangibility right it's why we tend to
lean towards finite instead of infinite
it's time it's why we like
uh metrics because they're easy to
measure and so what ends up happening
is the um uh the
person the the the visionary if you want
to call the person
becomes the tangible representation of
the vision
so we say we follow the person but in
reality what we're doing is following
the ideals that they espouse
so whether it's a whether it's business
or whether it's
uh politics or whether it's social
change
we say i follow martin luther king but
what we're actually saying is i follow
the vision that he represents
so the person becomes the
personification the representation the
tangible manifestation
i can't think of any more tion words the
of the vision and so we follow the
person but in reality we're following
what they espouse
um we follow what they stand for um
because that's the ideal because we're
only following the person if there's an
absence of vision and we follow a big
personality
like that happens too sometimes we can
mistake the two um
uh sometimes people tell us what we want
to hear and sometimes there's big
personalities and we can
follow the person but when they die
usually their vision dies too
the true test is when that person moves
on that their vision lives on beyond
them
and and their vision becomes our own um
it becomes a lot more tangible
okay uh pete uh brambaugh
from olathe kansas is it olath or olathe
i'll go with olaf um i want to use this
little book
to motivate my council members and
mobilize them around a shared purpose
activating a mostly dormant alumni
association of 20
27 000 individuals my question is what
is the best way to use the book to
accomplish this high purpose
so again we put this book out there like
i do with all my work i'll tell you
another funny little story
um uh i was i
attended this luncheon once it was a
couple years ago and
um i went by myself and sort of in
typical simon weird introvert
way i sort of like kept to myself and
like just walked around by myself and i
was getting lunch from the buffet
and i happened to be standing next to
somebody and we started talking and
really enjoying our conversation
turns out it was director baz lerman
totally cool
didn't recognize him he introduced
himself and um
i he told me how he thinks about his
work he says his work is like a child he
says when he
when he's producing something when he's
working on a project he gives it his all
he wants to raise this child he wants
this project to be the best thing it can
possibly be
and then when it's done he puts it out
into the world and it goes off and lives
a life of its own
and he goes on to the next project and
he says people will come up to him on
the street and say oh my god
i love moulin rouge and he always
replies oh
how is he i haven't seen him in ages say
hi for me it's kind of that like it's
out there and does its own thing
i have the same belief about my work you
know and i love
that i love that he he he said that so i
put this book out there not having no
clue what it was going to do or where it
was going to go
and to your point pete i've discovered
that people actually use it
to spur this kind of motivation and
inspiration with their teams with the
with uh uh with their companies um i
found that companies and teams read it
together
uh and so one of the ways you can do it
there's a few ways that i've heard that
other people are doing it
one is they gift it to everybody so it's
sort of a little more on the on the dl
uh uh where they gift it to everybody
and somebody says
this is great we should use this so it
becomes their idea um another
way i've heard it done is um
bringing it to a meeting and uh and
bringing out one of the quotes and
saying i think this i think this
inspires us like why haven't we done
this like
you know we this is very inspiring can
we talk about what our opportunities are
um so i would say whatever works for you
um
is the best um uh maybe even just share
it with a couple people share your copy
with a couple of people
and say can what do you think of us
using this
to inspire uh some change in the next
meeting um
but uh but it has been used for sure um
as i've heard so um definitely
definitely holding something up as a
prop and having it come from the book
is more organic than it coming from you
people for some reason are more
comfortable something coming from an
outside source
um uh good okay sarah nicole the wrath
girls from swindon
good to see you again um uh we are stuck
by how the how infinite the message is
so we wondered uh if you had read finite
ninth games by james cars when you wrote
togethers better
looking forward to leaders last book
club
hmm um okay so uh i noticed that as well
i actually made reference in the back to
the in this book i realized
to finite and infinite i noticed um i
a friend of mine brian collins gave me
dr carso's book
years ago and so i was already a lover
of his work in a devotee to finite
infinite even though i
i had no idea what to do with it and it
wasn't until years later
that i realized an opportunity to build
on dr carso's work and offer something
actionable that we could use to change
our mindset for the for the game we're
in
to really use his work as a foundation
um i honestly don't remember the exact
year that i was given the book but i i
think it's safe to say
that i did that i had read the book
because i'm using the language so
exactly how cars meant it so uh
yes i do believe i had read uh finite
infinite games
uh before i wrote this book um any live
amy questions hello amy davies um in
regards to
the publisher saying no to doing the
book with people telling you no this is
crazy this can't be done
how do you overcome that and continue to
believe in yourself and your vision to
make it become a reality
so um my my actual publisher the guy who
actually decides to give me a contract
and publish me
um you know i had two books out already
i had start with y out and i had leaders
last out and
um nobody expected either of those books
to do well and they both did well
and so i i i think he was a little more
like willing to take a bet on me
which he did and he and i were and
continue to be a great partnership he's
still he's still my publisher
uh and we're dear friends now it's known
each other for 12 or 13 years now
ooh everything's moving around look at
that wait i can't do it
there there's the crown there's the
there's the book club it's
there we go anyway um
uh i think you know i was this i think
goes to the point of good good trust and
good leadership which is i was actually
shielded from a lot of the pressure
um all of the when his ceo called him
and said you're crazy why are you doing
this don't do this i actually was
unaware that that was happening until
later
he took a lot of the heat for me so i
think that's a sign of good leadership
which is he he protected me and let me
go make my book
um he believed that i was onto something
and i kept showing him
progress like here's the story that i
came up with and here are the characters
that we've come up with
and hear the illustrations and hear the
things that we're planning on doing and
he could see it coming to life
he though he had no imagination for what
it could be at the beginning
i had a kernel of an idea of what it
could be um as he saw it coming to life
he got more confident
but he trusted me and i trusted him um i
the only
fights we had were you know the scented
book like change the pricing structure
those those were difficult conversations
because they wanted to make it temporary
and a promotion and
but and so what i so you have to play
your politics and so i never i never
heavy-handed i never sort of demanded
and said this has to happen and i never
lost my temper or anything like that
but i would make allowances i'd say well
okay listen i know that the scented page
adds cost to the production
so why don't we make it um in the first
edition
and if it sells well um then we'll keep
it and if it doesn't sell well
are you guys okay making it promotional
for the launch and all the sales team
would say yes yes because they're okay
with the lower sales numbers
you know at the beginning and turns out
it sold well so we kept it in
um so i i had to believe in my own in my
own product as well
because if it didn't sell well we would
have to reduce the cost so
um it was it was it was it was a
it was a journey it was life
life imitating art as oscar wilde said
uh he uh he actually he said i find more
often that
uh uh life imitates art more than art
imitates life i think he said
okay let's do another question victoria
i just for this comment
i wrote my name on the back and passed
it to the person who was taking over my
position
i encouraged them to sign and continue
to pass this book around when they were
ready
oh my god i love that did you hear that
what was her name victoria
victoria alcacer says that she when she
was done with her job she signed the
book
gave it to the person who replaced her
and they've continued to sign the book
and pass it on
to the to each person who's who's uh
who's who's taken that job which i
absolutely love and this book was about
giving
it was very important to me that this
book would be given as a gift i didn't
want
i i was more interested believe it or
not for people to buy this book for
someone else than to buy this book for
themselves
which is why the very first page we put
to and from by the way that is my
handwriting
we put to and from the book is designed
to be
a gift so i absolutely love that it was
passed down and gifted down
and it continues to be signed i adore
that oh great idea
chrissy simon seaman seaman um
what steps can i take to help find my
vision
the concept sounds great but feels
confusing and hard to attain can you
please
expand on this absolutely so let's talk
about two different things let's talk
about vision and let's talk about why
so i talk about vision and just cause uh
as synonymous terms
um so uh i think we put too much
pressure on ourselves
that you have to have a vision come up
with your vision especially especially
young people today
because everybody's comparing themselves
to steve jobs you know
uh not everybody's a visionary leader
like not everybody steve jobs or richard
branson or martin luther king like
you know sarah sarah blakely you know
not everybody is visionary
it's a very small percentage of the
population that we would call visionary
they live in their imaginations we don't
have to come up with a vision but we do
have to find a vision
so if there is a vision that you've
heard from someone else that you believe
in that inspires you that gives you
goosebumps
it says that's that's what i've been
trying to say they put into words the
way i feel
then take that vision and make it your
own so you can take somebody else's
vision
and make it your own it's like the
previous question you know do we follow
the person or do we follow
the vision you may find the person but
it's really the vision that you believe
in
and so you can choose to follow the
person or you can just say that vision
is now mine
um and that is perfectly good and and
and
useful um uh uh you know i talk about
the vision that we all share
anyone who's here probably we all share
the same vision which is
we all believe in building a world in
which the vast majority of people
wake up every single morning inspired
feel safe wherever they are and end the
day fulfilled by the work that
we do uh that is the vision that we all
subscribe to which is why we keep coming
to these book clubs and enjoying each
other's companies
we're all in the same path now take that
vision make it your own if that's
something write it down
claim it that's that's the only way this
thing is going to come to life
is if all of us are working in our own
way to bring that vision to life because
certainly none of us can do it alone
it's going to take all of us
now that's vision a why is different a
why comes from your past it is
who you are it is the foundation of of
what inspires you it's your spark if you
want to call it that
uh it's the thing that gets you out of
bed in the morning and it's very often
the foundation
of a vision one comes the past it is
objective a vision is about the future
it is subjective
there are many ways to find your why i
wrote a book called
find your why the reason i wrote that
book is because for eight years people
complain that
they read start with why and i never
told you how to find it in the book and
they complained so we wrote find your
way eight years later
um also uh um
if on our on our website start uh what
is our website called
simonsenic.com uh we have a start with
white class
of which we reserve um for uh uh for
people who
um um who are going through hard times
right now
we've allowed for it to be for free for
some people which is very important
um and so you can go there and there's a
whole class that only takes two hours to
find your why
um uh which is a really really wonderful
class
um and i can tell you a fun way to do it
really quickly it's called the friends
test
um find a friend you love uh who loves
you back
the kind of friend you could call at
three o'clock in the morning and they'll
take the call
or you could call them at three o'clock
and uh they could call you and you take
the call
don't do this with family don't do this
with spouse don't do this with a
boyfriend or girlfriend those those
relationships are too close
do with a friend you love and ask them
this question
why are we friends and they're going to
look at you like you're crazy because
you're asking them to put into words
something that exists in the part of the
brain
that controls feelings and behavior but
not language and then you
you you say come on and you use the word
what what specifically is about me then
i know you'd be there for me no matter
what
and they're going to struggle and
they're going to start describing you i
don't know you're
trustworthy and smart and funny and you
have to play devil's advocate
yes that's the definition of a friend
what specifically is it about me that i
know you'd be there for me no matter
what and they're going to go through a
few rounds of trying to describe you
you're going to continue to play devil's
advocate you're going to drive them
crazy and eventually they'll give up
and they'll start describing themselves
i don't know my friends told me when i
did this
i don't even have to talk to you simon i
can just sit in a room with you and i
feel inspired
and i got goosebumps in fact i'm getting
them right now
so the point is is they will say
something that you will have an
emotional response either goosebumps or
you're well up
um and what they're doing is they're
articulating the value you have in their
lives in other words that's your why
it's the value you have in their lives
it's who you are and you can do this
with multiple friends
and uh they'll give you very very
similar if not the exact same answer
it's kind of spooky because
the thing you give to the world is the
thing they value so there's a way to
find your why
um anything over there otherwise
gary avails how are you 45 sorry
i'm drinking a smoothie filled with all
kinds of nonsense in it
um whatever i could find that wasn't run
out
okay gary's asking me a very very
specific question uh
page 45 i'm going there yes page 45 the
quote
the quote is here's the picture
uh if the challenge we face doesn't
scare us then it's probably not that
important
yes gary so why do you say this and why
is fear so important versus
other primary emotions so he he says why
do i say this and why is fear
so important versus other primary
emotions
i don't think uh it's necessarily about
fear but i think something that scares
us means that it's big that it's worth
it
that it intimidates us um i think we can
have multiple feelings at the same time
we can be
inspired excited and afraid at the same
time we can be scared by what we have to
do
so when you when you when you imagine
doing something different it could be
something
and by the way a lot of the things are
in our own mind to to one person
quitting your job
because you're dissatisfied is an easy
decision for some it's a very very
difficult decision
it's it's not a writer it's not a right
or wrong so to say am i going to do this
i really want to do this everything it's
like jumping off the high dive like i
really want to do this i really want to
do this but my goodness it's so high up
but i really want to do this and i
believe that i can do this and i know
it'll be an amazing experience and i
know i should do this and this is going
to be fun
but this is i'm looking down and it's
really high up okay here we go there's a
leap of faith
um and i think scary challenges if if a
challenge doesn't scare us
you know then
then i you know you think about making
incremental change in our lives or in
the lives of others
you know i think if it's difficult and
and if it scares us a little bit it
means
it's probably worthwhile it's probably
something important
something small and and minuscule though
important
um though good uh will it produce uh
profound change in our or someone else's
lives or the lives
of the of the world we live in so i i
i i'm all and maybe this is my own
personal bias
but i i like a difficult problem and i
like looking
going how are we going to do this uh
difficult things mean that you have to
rely on other people easy things you can
often do by yourself
um and i think doing something that
requires help
is going to be a good is going to it's a
good problem to solve and means other
people want to solve it with you
um let's move on there's a question here
from shiny what is the meaning of the
photo on the book the image of the
cover shoddy yes hi what is the image on
the book
the crown um so the crown sitting in the
glass in the grass
uh the crown is the uh is the metaphor
we use for
for leadership and it's available to
anyone it's
it's i can't get it it's the way this
program works i don't even know how to
point there it is um
we just because at the end i talked
about how the the
the bully the boss you know
takes off his crown and gives it to
to uh charlie we called him um
and then charlie immediately takes it
and passes it on and this crown becomes
the symbol
of of of of power that we give away
um and so i think we were all just
struck by this metaphor
that we we decided to to to put on the
ground and says it belongs to no one and
it's available to anyone
and be the leader you wish you had
anyone anyone can
can can hold the power and share it so i
think it was just
it was that metaphor that it's available
it doesn't belong to anyone
it never does um nice question
uh laura clark asked i'm struggling she
says
how do you know as a leader when
performance issues in your team are due
to your leadership
or maybe they just don't have the
capability to deliver in the role you
ask
uh thanks uh uh for your always
insightful words
um this is one of the hard things about
leadership
um you know is it us um or is somebody
actually struggling so
if if more than one person is struggling
we you know there might be process
issues it might be us um i think
feedback is important
um there has to be two-way feedback so
um and also being willing to accept
i think i think it's how you show up as
the leader as well that we'll reveal
these things
you know if we show up saying you've got
to get your performance back up what's
the problem i think
we then the pressure we're exerting may
actually exacerbate a problem
um but to give someone help and coaching
and say how are you doing you know
keep me posted i'm here to help um and
at some point it becomes very obvious
that for example you put someone in a
job to be an accountant and they're no
good at math
and you know you give them enough runway
you give them enough
time and coaching to see if they can
learn the skill or if
if they have the skill and and in time
it starts to be
become readily available that that
they're struggling
um and the most important thing is is if
they're in a job that they can't do
not only will their per not only is
their performance down which which is
which um which is a struggle for for the
company
um but they're unhappy because nobody
wants to do a job they can't do
and nobody wants to do a job they're
struggling to do in other words there's
and so
to sit down and have honest
conversations like are you okay and what
we'll tend to find in these people
is their stress is much higher than
other people on the team
you know we all have periods of high
stress but what you'll see is continued
high stress
and so that may be showing up in other
ways too so they may be short-tempered
they may be punchy
they may be um they they may be um
you know just a little difficult to work
with for more than uh
one person and so probably a good sign
that there's high stress probably a good
sign that they're struggling
probably a good sign good time for a
difficult conversation
um but yeah time time reveals it um i
think one of the things you have to do
is offer a little bit of patience i know
in this marketplace it's a lot harder
um uh sometimes we just don't have the
runway but if you can
that's what we want to do it is a
difficult it is a difficult thing but i
love that you're asking the question
i really love that here's one from
portugal uh from nuno uh
fel guidas my portuguese is not good
uh uh hello nuno uh
what do you prefer social distance or
physical distance um
i think physical distancing is the thing
we're supposed to be doing i would like
us to be socially close i never want
people to be socially distant
we want to be socially close and
physically physically apart
uh during these strange times um
okay what else um i don't think i can
tell you any more stories
oh thank you and somebody i love this
one
on one on one-on-one coaching one-on-one
coaching from one
i get it i get it one-on-one coaching i
get it
very good how about a t-shirt with a
quote from the page with the kids
looking at the big wall
ah okay so juan from one-on-one coaching
i was why not a t-shirt
with uh with the quote from the kids
looking over the big wall
funny you should ask i've been wanting
to do
um a t-shirt inspired by this book for a
while
and i'll be totally honest i don't know
what to do so we've decided should we
we've thought about should we just do a
quote and nothing else
should we do one of the pictures should
we do the kids should we do the the
you know the kid handing the crown away
just just an image
should we do one of the images on the
back and the quote on the front which
quote should we do
so if you have any ideas or suggestions
uh should we do a quote on the t-shirt
should we put an image on the t-shirt
should we put a quote and if so which
quote do you like um
tell us in the comments or if you have
suggestions for the kind of t-shirt we
could make please email
book club at simoncynic.com send us your
send us your suggestions and uh we'll
take a look
we'll crowdsource it uh we'll take a
look what your suggestions are which are
your favorite quotes which are your
favorite
images and we'll make the t-shirt so
i i definitely want to make one just
been struggling what to make you know do
i put the wall with kids looking at it
kind of a weird t-shirt i don't know
let me know what you like and we'll make
the t-shirt thank you one i really
appreciate that
um brandi anger from wisconsin
um i have an idea to ask my entire team
to
read together is better and refer back
to it as we all look for motivation to
return to the office as opposed to
continuing to work remotely
true i miss my team together is
definitely better
any other advice for me on this front
i think what you just said is the best
thing you can do
um i'm i think to call your team and
when you have the next time you have
your
your your next team zoom call uh
tell them i think be open about it say i
miss us i miss the team i miss
saying hi in the hall i miss getting
lunch i miss the chitta
chit chat we have as we walk into the
meeting and the chit chat we have as we
walk out of the meeting
because at the end of the day it's not
the meetings that we build trust it's
not the zoom calls we build trust
it's what happens in between the
meetings it's all those little human
interactions all those little details
that we've been deprived of
for too long now um and uh
uh i think you should tell them i think
you should tell them you say and tell
them you're trying to think of things to
remind us
that together is better and and you can
have you can
maybe even every every uh huddle you
have if you do a weekly huddle huddle
um maybe read uh one of the chapters you
know one of the little sections and
share the quotes
and then for your huddle exercise go
around and ask people how it makes them
feel or what
you know which is their favorite thought
but but i think it is a
great thing to do to simply tell your
team how much you miss them and how much
you love them
and and try and think of the details the
actual things you miss the innocuous
things that nobody thinks are important
like i miss it when you know sarah would
walk into my office every morning and
bring me a cup of coffee and then walk
out like
the little things that that we're
missing out on try and be specific
and and and and create imagery and that
they can
that they can remember too uh
what else we got um
what is your inspiration for writing for
the quotes
like where do i get more where do i get
the quotes from
even when do you write them down and how
do you remember them
so um so the questions were where the
quotes come from
how do i remember them where do i write
them down so funny story
uh that's kind of what how i started
using twitter so
when twitter was an early thing uh
i signed up for like everybody else to
see what all the hubbub was about and
then if you remember the early days of
twitter
people were just posting about what they
were doing like i'm eating strawberry
ice cream
and i tried that for like three minutes
and thought it was
so stupid and so i stopped using it and
so i had
like no tweets um and
i would think of these things in in
conversation i would say something to
someone
and i'd be like ooh that's interesting
and i'd write it down and i had
all these like torn off pieces of paper
and napkins and sugar packets
that were literally i'd keep in a binder
clip all these ridiculous pieces of
paper like the little bits of
inspiration that i was having and the
quotes that i'd be writing down
and i had this horrible fear that i was
gonna lose them all and so i'm like hey
i have this twitter account
um i'm just gonna keep them there so
every time i had a crazy little thought
or a little quote
or something i would say in a
conversation that i'd be like ooh i
gotta write that down
um i would turn on my twitter and just
put the quote there and it became just a
filing cabinet just for me it wasn't
intended to have followers i literally
was using twitter as a filing cabinet
and i never interacted with anybody on
twitter
um i just kept using it as a filing
cabinet and people kept following me to
read these these little quotes which i
thought was fantastic so it was so fun
for me
is there was just a repository and it
became something that other people were
enjoying
too and more important sharing them with
other people so
that became my primary place to store my
quotes
but they very often happened in the
middle of conversations um
you know uh somebody's you know giving
somebody advice on
starting a business and i would say
something like look it doesn't matter
when you start it doesn't matter where
you start all that matters is that you
start and i'd be like ooh let's
write that one down i'll i'll use that
piece of advice again one day
um and that's all it was i think i'm not
unique in this respect i think
lots of us say things that we find
interesting in our own conversations
with people especially when we're in a
giving mode
giving advice sharing trying to inspire
you know
uh leading like i think we often say
things and the trick is to
to capture them really quickly because
as quickly as we have those thoughts and
ideas
we lose them i actually carry a notebook
now um if i have ideas more than a quote
um i carry a little notebook in my back
pocket um well i used to and i had a
back pocket
uh no i just wear sweatpants um
uh uh but i i write them down
um you gotta write them down somewhere i
phone
notebook twitter whatever write them
down because you will lose them
and you never know when they'll come in
handy uh
tina lil yadal from houston texas
uh when we find a vision of the world
that we want to build and perhaps our
contribution to the playground the
organization starts small
how do we build to do more for example
if i am a consumer of a product i want
to volunteer or work for the company
who makes the product um how do i show i
have more to contribute to the cause
than just buying their products and
giving great reviews
um uh well there's multiple ways to do
that
um you have to you asked you gave a
specific example so that's use that
example
any company worth that salt that has a
good vision
wants other people to share in that
vision
so airbnb for example is about
connection and inclusion and so you
don't have to work for airbnb
to practice inclusion you can be a host
and you can also not be a host you can
just practice togetherness connection
and inclusion
southwest airlines is about you know
fairness
uh and freedom um and if you've ever
flown southwest airlines which i know
you have because you're in houston
um uh uh
as you know when you board a southwest
airlines flight it's kind of different
from every other airline like
there's other airlines that are very
very good that i enjoy flying
and when you stand in line you kind of
just stand in line and wait to board the
plane
and that's kind of all you do southwest
everybody talks to each other have you
ever noticed that have you ever noticed
that in the southwest line
you just talk to the people in line with
you and everybody's really friendly
in other words go ahead and live the
southwest values because all of these
organizations with the vision
want want the vision to spread people
ask me um
often you know how can i help and my
answer is always the same
please practice the things i talk about
please be the leader you wish you had
because i imagine this world and
inspired safely fulfilled
other people share that vision none of
us can do it alone it's going to take
all of us working all over the place to
do it
so um if if the if the company offers
council
advice on on what to do follow it and if
you can discern the vision
uh believe in it and try and bring it to
life in other other places
um here's one from from malaysia
from les pang fung i've been curious
about this ever since purchasing the
book
how and why did you choose this smell to
represent the optimism scent
great question so
the the the nose that's the official
name the nose
of uh 1229 is a woman named dawn
goldworm she's uh apparently well known
as a nose in the nose industry um
uh in the scent industry and she comes
from you know designing
um a lot of perfumes before she started
her own company
and um
when we uh when we got together she has
a process
and she took me through it she took me
through this process where she asked me
a ton of questions
about my personality about my vision
about what i want to do and then she
went away
and she's synthetic so she can
see colors and and and smell like she
smells things in color
it's kind of amazing like she'll smell
something and say oh that's like a
greenishy blue
you know um uh but she went away and she
designed the scent based on
the answers i gave her in this process
that she took me through
and she brought me back three options
and she said
what do you think of these and i smelled
all three and the one that i fell in
love with was the one she predicted i
would fall in love with
was this one and ostensibly it's the
smell of optimism
but it's really the smell of my
personality so if i ask her what's it
made of she'll say high notes
with some low notes she'll say because
she knows that i'm bright but there's a
little bit of edge underneath and
so she tried to capture some of those
those those oaky notes in there as well
those woody notes um and so i i remember
when that when it first came out
uh a friend of mine
a few friends of mine said simon we love
the scent and i told this to dawn i'm
like dawn
my friends love the scent and dawn
smiling says of course they love the
sound they love you
because the sense is a representation of
you i thought that was so fun
but we've heard some really funny
stories that have come out of this
there was one story we heard uh as a
as a guy we work with who uh
he would get nervous before he went into
big meetings
and he would actually smell the scent
to bring up his spirits before he had a
big presentation
to to give and we heard about this
and we called the manufacturer who makes
the pages and we said can we just
buy some pages from you and we got a
stack of pages with no book
and we sent them to him and said here
for your next set of meetings and we
sent him a whole stack of smelly pages
um but it really does smell is very very
powerful smell more than any of our
other senses
is most closely related to memory um
it's
it's you know when we smell things it
takes us back more than photographs more
than things we hear
um it's very closely related to memory
and so we i i've loved hearing how
people have used the scent
um even outside the book and uh we used
to have a candle i think we don't have
any more left
i think we're sold out we made a bunch
of camels of of this scent
that was the smell of optimism candle
because i thought it would be fun to do
that
and because i wanted to burn it in my
house um and
i think we just sold out recently uh and
i don't think we're gonna make any more
um we'll do a couple more questions one
one more question
uh here is joanna who's the mom and emma
who's her eight-year-old uh gansel uh
from the
for the mummy daughter book club in the
uk i knew it was the uk because i could
see how you spelled mummy
um uh so from emma from the
eight-year-old she asked
uh how can you make and keep friendships
during the pandemic when you can't
really meet anyone
it is much harder emma as you're
learning to to maintain
friendships uh during the pandemic we're
at a distance um and it's the same for
for the adults which is it's harder for
us to maintain and build trust
at our companies when it's when it's um
when where it is
it takes more work and so um
ask mom if you can have permission to
to just have zoom calls or or facetime
calls with your friends
um and uh and try and do that try and
talk to people
and and ask them how they're doing the
most important thing is to check in with
your friends
say how are you you know find out say
hey
it's been it's been hard are you okay
what are you doing to help pass the time
like
show an interest in in how your friends
are doing um
as opposed to just reporting on on you
know what you've seen or what you've
done
um but it takes more work and and phone
calls are great too
you don't always have to see them it's
just sometimes talking to people
and giving them your full attention so
when you're talking to them you're only
talking to them you're only with them
you're not doing something else on the
side
also that can help but but checking in
with people and
and asking them how they're doing and
how they're feeling and listening
it's a great time to learn to listen and
and you are definitely old enough
uh to learn to do that wonderful skill
um so thank you emma i love
i love that question and mom is on here
and just says thank you simon
oh great well you're welcome joanna nice
to meet you emma
um uh and hopefully one day we'll meet
in person too
uh and so i'll just finish up the
question here which comes from
joanna um how can i teach a a young
child some basic leadership skills for
surviving education
and their first job how can i help them
to grow an infinite mindset
um so when i was researching leaders eat
less i was
reading about parenting and sort of the
impact parents have on their children
um and you know it makes you wonder like
where how do kids become the kids they
are
you know where do they get their values
you know and things like that and it
turns out it's not all from the parents
you know kids are very much influenced
by their teachers their friends
you know uh the people they meet um
extended family
and that's why you can have two kids
from the same parents you know
completely different
in so many respects
because kids kids come together in all
different ways
however what i learned from the research
is that there are two things
that every single child learns from
their parents and this is universal
around the world cross-cultural
every single child learns uh how to
treat themselves
and how to treat others that comes from
the parents
and so i think if you want to grow an
infinite mindset
i think practicing giving practicing
charity
[Music]
learning that sharing is a good thing
and sometimes a difficult thing for a
kid to learn um
um and the hard skill of listening like
and the way we'll get we're gonna teach
listening is we're gonna practice
listening
and so when emma's having a bad day just
you know are you a good listener
are you good at saying tell me more um
there's a great book it's on my desk
somewhere
oh it's holding the computer up so i
can't show you i've talked about it
before
it's i'll just hold up and i'll hear it
i'm going to drop down a little bit
okay i had to talk to kids so lis kids
will listen and listen so kids will talk
it is a parenting book but it's a
phenomenal book for any adult to learn
how to
i recommend it to in companies um
and so uh uh joanna um
this kind of this book how to talk to
kids so kids will listen listen so kids
will talk
um uh will help you perfect
uh your listening skills and then as you
do them emma will learn them too
okay and i think that's where we're
gonna end
um thank you so much everyone for
joining
um apparent lots and lots and lots of
t-shirt ideas coming in thank you thank
you thank you we're gonna go through
them all
keep the t-shirt ideas coming in uh book
club at
um simonsenic.com we'll go through them
all and we'll let you know
uh what t-shirt we come up with we'll
announce it on social media
uh i love this idea of crowdsourcing
this um also
uh just a reminder i think it's still
live otherwise i'm gonna speak out a
turn and we'll
cause a little panic but i think we
still have a discount code for book club
uh if you want to go and take any of our
classes we did this just for book club
um get 20 off uh for any of our classes
book club rules uh one word book club
rules book club rules
um if you want that that's just for us
uh and this is officially
the last book club assuming i don't do
another one
um thank you everyone for coming i it is
the highlight of my week i love doing it
i look forward to it
uh thank you for all the questions i
love that you came from all over the
world to join
and uh we'll see you real soon take care
of yourselves take care of each other
see you soon everyone